I uh I have a television so I'm going to
spend some time here to tell you some
things
and Sir you're doing a great job but
you're so quick with that stick so why
don't you sit because I may never be
here again
I want to acknowledge so many people
that made Erin Brockovich but really the
main person
um Stephen Soderberg you truly just made
me want to be the best actor that I I
suppose I never knew I could be and I
made every attempt stick man I see you
so I thank you for really making me feel
so
I love it up here
anyway I start working for him again in
two days so I can get to you later but
come on Mom and just Francis and Marcus
and Mike and everybody who's watching at
home Kelly Emma everybody I love the
world I'm so happy thank you